[Musique]
joachim j'ai discuté avec ta voisine
aujourd'hui il cherche un bandana fest
maman je suis suite moi j'suis pas
postiers vous connaissez cet homme nous
a plu les colombiens sont parvenus à
mettre au point un procédé qui permet de
mélanger la cocaïne avec du ciment
ce qui la rend totalement indétectable
sont arrivés sur ce chantier
c'est le chantier de la famille de
almeida unis faire venir un cousin
éloigné du reymond youtube switching la
moins d'une semaine pour faire de vous
un vrai portugais non non je vous plais
pas car si je vais faire le toit ou vrai
pour tous les portugais pour tous car
c'est l'hélicoptère en nous gouvernent
ou le coup de terre jamais alors que
souvent faire loire arrête de faire son
vin c'est très bien c'est un chef ou
surtout de toujours maintien j'espère
qu'il va la trouver vite cette colère à
vendre mieux
[Musique]
je côtoie qualité manquent un peu de
vous mais j'ai une balle en est quand
même là c'est pas compliqué je commence
content pour tout cas l'on a rappelé il
est doué quand même
on dit aussi qu'on annonce avoir les
changes entre grandes et ceux-ci sont
pour beaucoup
jean lacoste en grâce
[Musique]
les profils carrelage
il arrive souvent de se passer là tout
va bien se passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quitte pas chef chez ce que c'est
[Musique]
comment les scop
ça va la dérange pas trop ces missions
cocaïne ou l'amour est dans ce chantier
[Musique]